okay
uh hey everyone
uh welcome to the last talk of uh robert
speech recognition uh challenge uh at uh
hugging face
the last talk will be given by schengen
monk or who is a research engineer at
meta ai or working on speech the talk is
about xlsr which is a large-scale
model for cross-lingual uh spiritual
speech representations and which is
which this is the model that you will be
using this uh
for for the sprint
so uh without any delay i'll hand it
over to you shangen
cool um thanks raj
for the introduction and
also thanks um hanging face for having
having me here um
so yeah hi everyone i'm i'm chun khan
i'm research engineer from meta ai
mainly working on speech translation and
speech representation learning
so today i'm going to talk about um
xlsr
our recent work on large-scale speech
representation learning
on as many as 128 languages so this is a
joint work with my colleagues at meta ai
and also patrick here at at hacking
phase
so overwat um
x l sr is a wave to back 2.0 model
so uh let me first give you a quick
introduction um on wave 2 back 2.0
um basically we look back 2.0
is a self-supervised model for learning
speech representations
so
this during process requires
only unlabeled speech audio data which
is
much easier and cheaper to get
compared to
labeled data
and um it provides pre-changed models
for many downstream speech tasks
like speech recognition
speech translation speaker
identification
language identification and so on
so
this unsupervised
pre-training approach is very helpful
to
to reduce the need of label data in the
downstream tasks
many of you may need only a small amount
of label data
during model fine tuning
to achieve results on the downstream
tasks
for example we evaluate on the speech
recognition task using the liberal
speech benchmark
we showed that with vector borneo
can beat
the previous
state of the art with 100 times less
labeled data
so the previous state-of-the-art
leverage around
100 hours of labor data while in
contrast
the wave to back 2.0 model
outperforms it with only one hour of
labeled data
this technique can save a lot of efforts
and and cost on on
data labeling
moreover when we use the same amount of
label data
as that uh you was used in the previous
state of the art uh with the active
point model can perform even better uh
with a larger improvement of 3.6 um
decrease on the wear rate in the liver
speech benchmark
so going back to xlsr
xlsr is a multilingual wave to back 2.0
model so it's a single model that is
trend jointly on 128 languages
and supports 128 languages in this one
single model
we use a large amount of unlabeled
speech audio data to trend this model
and we scaled the model size up to 2
billion parameters
so in this way
we are able to make the model
generalize well across different
languages and domains
we verified the
effectiveness of
this model of various dungeon tasks like
speech recognition speech translation
and speech classification
but um however please note that like
xlsr is not limited to to these uh tasks
mentioned above um
we we hope to work with the community to
apply and uh validate xos art on more
speech tasks
and here is a comparison between xlsr
and
xlsr53
which is the previous
largest multilingual wave to back 2.0
model
we can see that
the data scale and model scale
have increased significantly
from xlsr53
to xlsr
for example we scaled the number of
languages by 2.4 times
reaching 128 languages
and we scaled
the amount of data by almost eight times
reaching 436
000 hours
and um we use data from five different
data sets
slash domains compared to three datasets
in the xlsr53
model training
we scaled the model size by almost seven
times
reaching around two billion model
parameters
we'll see later in the downstream task
evolution that
these skating efforts
result in huge performance improvements
so for
experimentation and different
application scenarios we train xlsr in
three
different model sizes
the
0.3 billion model to match the size of x
or sr53 on the previous state of the r
and we also
have the 1vd and 2bm models for more
model capacity to push the performance
limits
xlsr covers 128 languages but these
languages by nature do not have equal
number of speakers in the world and
equal amount of
open data for model training
we can see from the figure on the bottom
right that the data distribution by
language is very long-tailed
there are only 24 high resource
languages with more than
1000 hours of trending data
and there are 87
low resource languages which have less
than 100 hours of training data
one of the advantages of
multilingual models is that joint
training
or many languages
enables cross-lingual knowledge transfer
from high resource languages to the
resource languages
that is
learning on the low resource languages
can benefit from the learning on their
related high resource languages
this brings performance improvements to
the low resource languages without using
any more data in those low resource
languages
and this is very good news
because for low resource languages data
acquisition
is usually difficult and costly
well for high resource languages data
acquisition is relatively easier
next let me share let me show you some
evaluation results on the downstream
tasks
so the first one is the challenging
speech recognition benchmark
babel so we pick five languages from the
babel corpus
and use
the average were arrayed for evaluation
the babel corpus is consists of
phone call recordings which have heavy
background noises
and the data is no resource
with only 30 to 76 hours of data per
language
in this setting
xlsr 0.3 bdm model
outperforms the previous
state-of-the-art
xlsr53
with the same
model size
there's a significant improvement of 1.4
um on the on the world air rate
and um and this is because we
trend the xoxo model on much more data
the five languages are not only covered
by in-domain pre-training data from
babel but also covered by
out-of-domain pre-training data like box
lingua 107 compass
the latter provides additional useful
information and from the same language
and and this leads to the performance
improvement
we also see a clear trend that
increasing the model capacity unlocks
more gains
for the larger 1 billion and 2 billion x
osr model
we see that the decrease on the weight
error rate
is enlarged from 1.4 to three point nine
and and four point seven respectively
here's another um chinese speech
recognition benchmark
a future setting uh for ten languages in
the common voice
corpus
in this setting we only have um one hour
of labeled training data for for each
language
and they are crowdsourced from diverse
speakers in the common voice community
again
we see that xosr
0.3 billion model significantly
outperforms xosr 53
the previous state of the art
we noticed that
the performance can be improved a lot by
scaling
only the unlabeled data in the same
language while using the same small
amount of
label data
so this is a more
economic way
than increasing the label data
an example for this is swedish so if you
look at swedish
where
like xosr has 16 000 hours more labeled
data than the xlsr53
um
so this brings a large decrease of 6.7
on the phone
funding error rate
while it still use the same amount of
one hour labeled data
um another position is that out of
language data is helpful for example on
kyrgyz
xosr and xlsr53 have the same trendy
data
from convoys
but xosr contains more data for the
other languages the increased amount of
data in the other languages
especially those
similar languages from the same
language family as kyrgyz
helps the performance on kyrgyz
through cross-lingo knowledge transfer
lastly
we again see the trend that like
increasing xosr
model capacity in largest again
in this case from 1.1 for error rate
decreased to to 2.7 firing decrease in
the 2bn model
besides speech recognition
we also evaluate our models of
multilingual speech to text translation
the task is to build multilingual
translation models to translate speech
in any of the 21 languages into english
in this task
xosr 1 billion and 2bm models achieve
large improvements
on the mid resource and high resource
directions
on the 5 main resource directions xosr
2bm model improves the state of the art
by an average of
7.5 blue points
and on the 12 low resource directions it
improves the state of the r by an
average of nine
point two blue points
so similar to the case in um speech
recognition
we we find that
large xlr models can do much better
future learning
for example on the swedish to english
direction where there is only two hours
of label data
xosr 2bm model outperforms the previous
state of the art by as many as 19.3 blue
points
and similarly on the arabic to english
direction uh where we also have only two
hours of label data there's a
substantial improvement of 14.1 blue
points
comparing the the performance for exodus
that are 0.3 billion 1b and 2bm models
we again confirm the trend that more
model capacity in xo sr brings more
gains
here's another similar uh multilingual
speech attack translation task where we
want to build multilingual models to to
translate english speech into any of the
15 target languages
we also see um
we already see from from from the
previous experiments that like xlsr
brings large games to mid resource and
resource directions in this experiment
we instead focus on the high resource
side
and and take english as example because
um in general it's the highest resource
language in in speech resources research
in this setting
we compare xlsr models with english only
wave to vector models
and we see that like
our
large 1 billion and 2bm models
outperform these strong more lingual
baselines
and and this confirms that xlsr performs
well
across
languages regardless of the data
condition
and cross-lingual knowledge transfer
helps the low resource languages without
hurting much
the performance on on the high resource
languages
besides speech recognition and speech
translation tasks we also see the
benefit of
x-ray models on speech classification
tasks
for example
on the language identification task
where we test the identification of 33
languages using the vos lingua 107
coppers
um the the xos our 0.3 video model
outperforms the previous state of the
art by one percent error rate
um on another task the the speaker
identification task where we use the
voxlab1 dataset to test the
identification of around
1000 celebrity
voices
xos our 0.3 bdm model outperforms the
previous state of the r by 5.5
accuracy
so here is a
quick summary for xlsr basically xlsr is
our
latest multilingual wave to back 2.0
model
supporting 128 languages
we provide three model sizes 0.3 billion
1 billion 2 billion for different
application scenarios
the 0.3 bdm model consistently
outperforms the previous
state-of-the-art multi-lingual wavefact
10 model
namely xlsr53
and it's a drop in replacement
with identical model architecture and
equal model size
the 1v and 2bm models
have more model capacity
and this unlock more performance boots
especially on the mid resource and low
resource
languages
at the same time
these large xlsr models also perform
comparably or even better on high
resource languages like english when
compared
to large monolingual pre-trend models
so overall
it's suggested that
large xlsr models are universal models
for all the languages
they perform well across high resource
low immediate results and low resource
languages and they may may replace many
former multilingual or
more lingo with the vector oil models
for for better performance
so next i just want to share some
quick notes for using xosr models so
basically we release the pre-trend
models
fine-tuned multi-lingual speech
translation models for from both foreign
to english and in english to foreign
directions so these models are in three
different sizes 0.3 billion 1 billion
and 2 billion
you can use the original fair
signification to run model inference um
just just check out the way to back and
xosr example folders in the in the fair
seek github ripple
for the model links and instructions
and it's even more convenient
to use the implementation in the hacking
phase transformers library um we also
provide the example for this in the
fiercely
to fine-tune xlsr models or a new
language or a new data set by itself
using harkin phase transformers library
um patrick's actually uh wrote a really
nice tutorial and and provided great uh
detailed examples in this tutorial and i
strongly recommend you to check it out
um and if you'd like to try also
the first egg implementation
feel free to check out our note in the
xo star example folder um in the first
repo
all right so that's all for my
presentation uh thanks for your
attention and i'm happy to answer
questions now
uh thanks a lot changan uh for the great
talk uh and we have quite a few
questions
i'll just read it out to you
so everyone is asking uh i'm curious
about the upscaling approach do you have
any results or insights from different
values of alpha
and how about for monolingual batches
instead of multilingual sampling
language per batch
sure this is a good question um yeah so
i think upsampling
is kind of
a question for for many multilingual
models especially for marketing models
involves a lot of languages so for our
case uh we use temporary base um we just
follow the previous best practices
um so we use we just use temperature
based upsampling
with a temperature of two so we did try
with different
temperatures in this upsampling and find
this this one uh is generally provides
the best performance
so for the second question um for
batching
um
yeah so i think currently um
we didn't actually
uh
like deliberately match uh like mixing
the the
data from different languages in one
batch so the current batching strategy
um like we still target at um better
efficiency during training so we we kind
of
saw the languages saw the examples um by
their lens and like it's possible like
in some of the batches um is is purely
more lingual because it's designed may
decided by the
lens cool
uh the next question is by patrick
for speech translation the language
model was integrated within the
architecture and whereas for asr
language model booster decoding is used
mostly
so would it make sense to use the seek
to seek architecture for asr as well
yeah um yeah i think that's a good
question i think um
yeah definitely um
i think for sr
lmd coding can be very useful especially
for low resource
settings where we don't really have much
label data and lmd coding can can
provide additional
information on on the target language i
mean for sr is just in the same language
but you provide additional linguist
information to improve the decoding
results and at least i think for fear
seek we
do have the implementation for lmd
coding for for for the general bin
search decoding so that covers both
speech translation
and asr
so
the next question is also by patrick or
do you think a minimum amount of
capacity is required
for example could one pre-train a 100
million parameter model on 128 languages
or is this too much data for two little
parameters
yeah this is a good question um
so we built to be a model like we use a
lot of model capacity because like for
these 128 languages they
are
there may be very uh distinct languages
like um like from different language
families right and for multilingual
models they are interference issues
because like you may see like two very
different languages they are competing
for the model capacity so that's why i
want to use large model capacity to
ensure that we can minimize this
interference and and the model can
perform well
on
on all the languages
so back to the questions of small
multilingual models um one
one suggestion is that like
maybe
um we can try to
i think a trade-off for this like
instead of um training a small small
model on all the 128 languages maybe you
can try to trend it on um
on the languages from the same uh
language family and hopefully like there
are
smaller interference issues um on these
languages from the same language family
and hopefully like the small more single
models can can perform well on this
cool
the next question is about
whether using groups of language
families in pre-training would provide a
better performance than
grouping
unrelated languages together
yeah
yeah so yeah i think this is kind of uh
here is why i said um just now so
yeah i think um
yeah so i think a war like our our
initial goal is like trying to build a
universal model so i try just trying to
combine all the possible data and and
support as many languages as possible in
xlsr um but as i mentioned like
sometimes we need to want to make
tradeoff like say when you have really
have a
limit on the model size you want to
pursue smaller model size and in this
case maybe you want to trade this like
uh trade the the
number of like uh
supported languages
for
like better performance on smaller data
so in this case i i would say like um
training multilingual models understand
language family will make more sense um
yeah so i'm not really sure about this
this two-step pre-training uh mission
here um i guess maybe uh does that mean
like say you just pre-change the model
first by
linked family and then
by all the languages yeah i'm not not
super sure about the detail um you'd be
great if you can provide
some clarification
here we uh
we'll take two last questions
so it's uh
it's about like have you tried or will
you try to scale up even further
yeah the answer is yes um so we are
working on this so so we've seen like um
in the in the slides that like on on
speech recognition and speech
translation so there's a clear trend of
um
of um lsr
xlsr model um getting better
performance by by skating up right so
it's not even like substituting yet so
so currently well yes we are working on
even larger models to see if we can push
the limits further
uh uh awesome uh thanks a lot uh changan
we also reached our time limit uh thanks
a lot for the wonderful talk and uh
thank you all of you for joining us we
are very excited to see what you are
going to build in this challenge
um have a good evening have a good day
and thank you
all right thank you very much have a
good one everybody
bye everybody